NOOR ALI-HASAN: Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much for
coming to our talk.
My name is Noor Ali-Hasan.
And this is Julie Aranda.
And we are, both user experience
researchers on the Android Team
at Google.
So as you heard already
yesterday during the keynote,
we've made a bunch of changes
to notifications in Android N.
And today, we're going to
tell you about some research
that we conducted last
fall that's helping
us think about notifications
in a different way
for future Android releases.
So our agenda for today's
talk-- first, we're
going to tell you about
the specific study, how
we went about conducting it.
Then we're going to tell
you about some of the things
that we learned.
And then lastly,
we're going to wrap up
by talking about
what all of this
means for Android as a platform,
and what it means to you guys
as application developers.
All right.
So let's talk about this study.
So last fall, we wanted
to better understand
how our users deal
with notifications
and how notifications
impact their lives.
And when we started
thinking about it,
realized that notifications
isn't just about notifications.
It's about the
distractions-- interruptions.
So we decided to cast a
little bit of a wider lens
and look at this topic from the
sense of attention management.
So that includes everything from
interruptions from your device
to interruptions from
other people in your life
to the interruptions that
are going on in your head,
so thoughts that you might
have, to everything else that's
going on in your environment.
Our goals for this
study was, one,
to build a foundational
understanding
among our team who works on
notifications at Android,
inform the development
of Android N,
and then generate ideas for
future Android releases.
We wanted to understand
what do people
want to know when they
get a notification,
when do they want to
know those things,
and how should they be
presented so that they're
more actionable and effective.
So to answer those questions,
we took our entire team
to New York City for a week.
And we talked to
18 New Yorkers--
average, everyday
people-- about how
they dealt with notifications.
The first phase of the
study, we conducted
some unstructured interviews
with these participants
in their homes.
We've talked about
everything from how
do you deal with a
notification when you get it
to how do you manage your time,
how do you organize yourself,
how do you deal with reminders,
things of that nature.
But notifications is a sort
of thing that's fleeting.
It's in the moment.
And we didn't just want people
to tell us about notifications.
We wanted to
actually observe them
dealing with them in real life.
So we conducted some full
day, so eight hour to seven
hour observations, and
half day observations,
so about three to four hours,
where we're literally just
followed these folks
around during that time
and watched them do everything
from running errands
to child care.
And just kind of
watched what they did
when they got notifications.
And we observed all sorts
of things that had we only
interviewed them, I
don't think we would have
been able to capture as well.
So I'll give you an example.
One of the participants
that I observed,
during the three or four hours
that we were watching her,
she had received this email
but this piece, this article.
That she had written had
gotten published online.
And it was the first
time that she'd ever
had anything like that happen.
So here we watched her deal with
the initial email notification,
and then watched her you know
pull out her Chrome book,a
tablet, and her smartphone and
deal with all the notifications
that she got from
people on social media,
like her friends and family
liking the articles to like her
husband SMSing her about it
to like her mom calling her.
And that's the sort of
thing that, yeah, she
should probably could have told
us about it in an interview.
But it was an entirely
different experience
to watch her deal
with it in the moment.
After those first
two phases, we then
asked some of these
participants to come
to our office in New York City.
And we conducted some
buddy sessions with them,
where we asked them to
actually bring along
a couple of their friends.
And had some discussions
where the three of them
around notifications,
how they dealt with them.
And then we also did
some design exercises,
where we asked them to
imagine a world where
they had no limitations.
What would they want
notifications to be like?
And then at the end of the week,
our entire team-- so everyone
from people like us who are
UX researchers to designers,
engineers, product managers--
sat together in a room
and literally went through
every single piece of data
that we had collected that week
and organized it, and tried
to really see what sort
of patterns were emerging.
So the first thing
that we learned
is that notifications are
necessary for survival.
Now, if you think about
it, throughout history
we've actually received
all sorts of information
that's kind of similar
like a notification.
So for instance
for communication,
things like telegrams
or carrier pigeons.
For signaling danger, like the
town crier or the story of Paul
Revere or even smoke signals.
And even superheroes need a
customized notification system.
Even Batman-- yes, Batman--
he needs the bat signal.
That's right.
He needs the bat
signal in order to know
when to help out Gotham City.
But over time, each one of
these channels of communication
has become polluted
with other sources.
So for instance,
there was a time
when if you received
a letter in the mail,
it was probably some sort
of personal correspondence.
And right now, our mailboxes
are full of all sorts
of other stuff, like credit card
applications, advertisements,
things that we may
not necessarily want.
As a lot of you I'm sure
know, in the United States
right now we're going
through an election cycle.
And what that means
for a lot of us
is that we get
phone calls asking
us to vote for this candidate
or vote for this issue.
Today, we're inundated
with so much information.
And the people that we
talked to told us it
was really hard to focus
on the stuff that's
important in their life.
And that has led to
hyper-vigilance and addiction
to devices.
People told us that
it was really hard
for them to disconnect
from their devices.
There was our
participant, Denise,
who's a busy lawyer
and a first time mom,
and she freaks out if she
doesn't have her phone
with her for two seconds.
She worries what if she
misses something important.
Her husband, Andrew, thinks
that notifications are horrible,
because they make us
attached to our phones.
Now, the people we
talked to have set up
all sorts of different
coping strategies
to filter out the noise.
And some of these
coping strategies
are built-in features to
smart phones and some of them
are hacks.
The first strategy
that we heard about
is physically putting
your phone away.
One of the participants that
we talk to is a playwright.
And she told me about
how she would actually
put her phone in a
box and put it away.
And then once she wrote a
certain number of pages,
she would go back to the box.
And as a reward, she could use
her phone for 10 or 15 minutes.
Other participants told
us about not letting
different sources contact them.
So we heard of
participants going
into Settings and
disabling notifications
for different apps.
We heard of some
students telling us
about how sometimes when
in their study sessions
they'll actually exchange phones
and change their pass codes, so
that this way they won't
be tempted by their phones.
We also heard about participants
putting their phones
in airplane mode.
And then the most drastic
thing that we heard
is that00 there are some
participants who told us
that they will
literally uninstall app
if they feel like it's
to spam-y or too noisy.
The other tactic
that we heard about
is not letting your device
make noise, so putting it in
do not disturb mode, putting
it in vibrate, or silent.
And some people even
told us that this
is how their phone is
set up at all times.
And now this last
tragedy is doing nothing
and being constantly annoyed.
So these participants--
it wasn't that
they didn't know that
they can to make changes
or that they could do
all these other things.
It just wasn't
worth the trouble.
People told us that they
wanted more shortcuts
to learn about each notification
without having to look at it.
Because if you
think about it, it
does take some effort to
review a notification.
And the cost of checking
that notification
should be worth your time.
So one of the
participants we talked to
told me that the letter,
K, is a waste of her time.
And when she said that at first,
I was like a little confused,
because I didn't
really understand what
she had against the letter, K.
And then she actually told me
how she'll get a
notification for a message
and she thinks it's
something important.
And then she goes
through the trouble
of unlocking he phone
to look at the message.
And literally it is just the
letter, K-- shorthand for OK.
Screening information helps
people sift through the noise.
And participants told
us about different ways
that they did this.
So for instance, like
different notifications
from different apps that
have different sounds
or the colors of notifications.
And they wanted even
more ways to do this.
One participant, Flora,
told us about how
her phone has an actual
light for notifications,
and different notifications
have different colors.
And she knows that when
the light is orange,
it means that it's
her fan fiction app.
And she gets really excited,
because she loves that app.
Alexa told us about how
she gets a little confused
between the sounds of
two notifications--
one for a game app and
then one for Gmail.
And she wishes that she could
distinguish between the two
a little bit more,
because she probably
wouldn't be checking her
phone as often if she
knew it was from the game
as opposed to emails.
So what do people want to know?
Well, people told
us that they wanted
to know two primary things
with their notifications.
And I'm going to tell
you about the first one.
The first thing that people
told us that they wanted to know
is that people are the most
important notifications.
And this was hands down
every single person
we talked to said
this is number one.
This is their
number one priority.
And who a message is from
is more important than what
or when.
So when we're talking
about people notifications,
we're talking about
everything that's
like messaging, IM, chat,
email, all that sort of stuff.
Participant Flora told us that
those are the most important
to her, and she always responds
to those notifications.
But even within
people notifications,
there are people
in your life who
are more important
than other people.
It could be your spouse.
It could be your best friend.
It could be your
parents or your kids.
And for those people, you
reserve those channels
of communication.
Andrew told us there are
two things in life that
are going to get him in
trouble-- work emails and SMSes
from his wife.
So those are the two things
that he takes care of first.
And it makes sense that
these people notifications
are so important.
They help us maintain
our social connections.
They help us fulfill social
contracts and obligations
with other people.
And if you think about
it throughout humanity,
we've needed other people
in order to survive.
But we also found that
there's a certain etiquette
around online communication.
And there are consequences
when you don't
reply to someone soon enough.
Juan told us about how there
was a time when he broke up
with someone, because
that person did not
get back to him quickly enough.
And he knew that this person
had gotten his message,
because this he had
gotten the read receipt.
And we might laugh
about Juan and think
it's an extreme scenario.
But a lot of the
people we talked to
had this anxiety
around read receipts.
Now, another reason why
these people notifications
are so important is because
they just feel good.
It feels good to know
that there's somebody out
there who's sending
you message, who
cares about you, who needs you.
And we couldn't
put it any better
than our participant, Rachael.
She said notifications
from other people
make her feel like her existence
in the world is important.
She even told us how there are
times where her phone might
get a little quiet.
And she'll actually start
kind of like instigating
communications with
other people that she
hasn't heard from in a while.
She might send them a message
just so that that way,
she gets this positive
feedback loop.
JULIE ARANDA: So
what's the other thing
that people want to know?
So Noor just told you
people is most important.
Well, the other thing was people
want help with remembering
what they need to do.
So all participants told us
there's a lot on my radar.
I have these long mental
and physical to do lists.
And one person said, OK,
what's on my radar right now?
I have to clean the
chinchilla cage.
I have to remember to go to
Trader Joe's and pickup pumpkin
spice coffee later.
I've got to order my Prius keys.
I have to confirm a play
date for my son tomorrow.
She's like, I
could go on and on.
And someone else said I
have to return a modem.
I've got to call
Citibank to pay my bill.
I've got to return the curtains.
I've got a call the super
to fix my drain later.
We all have stuff
like this, right?
We've all got stuff that
we have to take care of.
Participants told
us about these.
They're trying to stay on top
of these tasks in their lives,
while they're managing all
these incoming interruptions
and notifications
that we are sending.
Alyssa said, "My life is
a series of close-calls."
She's a writer for a
newspaper in New York,
and she just got deadline
after deadline after deadline.
And she has trouble
juggling them.
Sometimes she forgets something
or just drops the ball.
Or sometimes she's very close
to forgetting something.
But at any moment, she's feel
something could be dropped.
A close-call's going to happen.
The most appreciated and
relied upon notifications
are ones that remind you of
something you need to do.
These bring relief.
These are when people want to
be notified, because they help.
"If I didn't have my calendar
reminding me, I'd be screwed,"
said Andrew.
I feel the same way for work
meetings and stuff like that.
Without a calendar,
where would we be?
And then we asked
people, so show us
how do you remember the
stuff you have to do?
And people showed us these
systems that they had.
Every one had some
kind of a system,
and there were all very complex.
They all included
multiple tools.
There was always
gaps and overlaps.
There was no perfect solution.
I don't think anyone
figured it out yet.
Some people-- like
for example, this one.
This person-- he put these
two notes on his door.
It's a German word.
I don't know if anyone
knows German here.
But it's-- oh yeah?
What does that say?
AUDIENCE: Keys.
JULIE ARANDA: Yes.
Bring the keys when
you leave the house.
So for him, he has
a complex system.
And this is just
one part of it--
to use physical
notes on his door.
We do that, right?
Does anyone do that?
I put boxes by the door.
And the types of tools we
heard were across the board.
There were like paper lists,
paper planners, digital lists,
digital apps, taking photos
to remember to do something,
taking screenshots
of a text message,
because there was something in
that text message you needed.
People hack together
all kinds of things
to try to remember these tasks.
This participant said,
"I keep the weekly
to do list to my planner.
I keep unread emails for
things I need to do long-term."
And we heard people
keeping these things unread
for like eight months, so
they would remember them.
And she said, "I'm just
trying to survive."
And we used this as inspiration
for the title of our talk,
because it reminds
us we all are just
trying to survive and
stay on top of the things
we need to do in our
lives, while managing
all these interruptions
and all these distractions
that we're getting
on our devices.
So when we looked at all
the different types of tools
that people use
to remember stuff,
they seem to fall into
this kind of process
for how to remember
to do things.
And the first stage
is just offloading.
So you remember like, oh,
I got to do this later.
You have to offload that idea,
so you can focus on doing it,
rather than focus
on remembering it.
And next you have to view it.
So you put all your stuff
together somewhere in a list
somewhere.
And you need to be able
to access it later.
And the third one is to
do the thing, so the thing
you need to get done.
And the last one is to check
it off when you're done.
And we highlighted
Do, because we
think this is where
notifications can help most.
And just focusing
on the Do section,
people told us the quality
they needed in a tool
to help them was like they
needed that alert-- that ping.
That's kind of the
most important thing.
And so people would use
things like putting things
in calendar, a digital
calendar, just for that ping,
even though it's
not an event per se.
Or they would email themselves
just to get that ping
and to get that the unread
email on the top of their list.
Taking pictures, like I said,
phone alarms, timers, telling
someone else to remind
me later, so offloading
that responsibility to
someone elss-- lots of tools
that people hacked
just to get them to do.
Someone said I need something
to pester me until I do it,
or I'll forget.
And Angie-- so she missed
the flight last time.
And this time she really didn't
want to miss that flight.
So she set a calendar reminder,
an alarm on her phone,
and she made her friend keep
texting her every 30 minutes
to make sure she'd get home
and get a good night's sleep
to wake up in the morning.
So she was so afraid
of missing the flight
that she triple booked
these different sources,
because she didn't believe that
any one would be enough to let
her remember task.
So how might our
notifications remind
people of what they need to do?
And I think it was probably
different with every service
or every app that you work on.
But I think for each
one, we encourage
you to think about your
service and which aspects of it
might be related to a task
that someone might need to do.
And how can you remind them
with your notifications?
OK, so leading into
this idea of how do
people want to know things.
We told you what
they want to know,
which is people and
stuff they have to.
But how should we notify them?
And it depends.
When we looked at all the
different notifications
our participants
told us about, there
was an interesting
intersection between the task,
so how enjoyable
it is and how much
you want to do the thing,
to how urgent it is.
And when we combine
these dimensions,
we get four types
of notifications.
So here's a framework that
I'll go into a more detail.
If you look at the
x-axis, this is really
like how much do you
want to do the task.
There are some things that
are just more fun than others.
And how urgent is it?
Is it something you
need to do right away?
Or can you put it off to later?
And this framework speaks
to how people should
be notified of something.
So going to this first one, the
green section-- the VIP stuff.
So this is the
enjoyable and urgent.
So these are the
VIPs in your life
that Noor just told you
about, because people are
so important to our survival.
These are the most
important notifications.
Some examples are a text from
your spouse, a baby-cam alert
telling you that
there's in the crib
or in the baby's
room, social event
reminders, because
these events are
important for our
social connections.
Remembering a friend's
birthday, we heard that a lot.
People really
wanted to remember.
And don't remind me the
day of the birthday.
But tell me in advance,
so I can do something
about the birthday.
Right.
"I wish I could something
like an Amber alert
for my parents, my ex-husband,
and my son's school,
so that those would
override everything else."
So for Alice, no matter
what settings you set up
on her phone that day, whether
she's in her yoga class
or whether she's teaching
her university course,
she needs to be reached at
all times by these VIP people.
So for her
notifications, those need
to stand out from the noise.
The next one will be called
mission-critical notifications.
So these are not enjoyable
things, or things
you don't like to do,
but they're important.
And often they're important
for your livelihood
or for your survival,
like work emails.
Right.
Those are important.
You've got to get
to those in time.
Renewing a passport,
which I don't think anyone
likes to do-- it's
just kind of a hassle.
But there are real ramifications
if you don't do it in time.
And anything with a
deadline-- that's important.
So for these types
of tasks, people
need to know if
there's a deadline
and exactly when it is,
so that they can plan it.
And they need to do it.
And Andrew, who is the lawyer
who hates his job-- he says,
"My work emails...
Those are the really
soul-crushing alerts.
To me, this is
kind of the essence
of the mission-critical stuff.
The next one is what we
call nagging reminders.
So these are unpleasant things
you don't really like to do,
but they don't have to be
done right away yet, so
like paying the bills or like
picking up your dry cleaning--
just like those errands that
add up-- system updates,
app updates, basically the
stuff that you go, ugh, still
have to do that later.
Shelly said, "I know I have
to pick up my dry cleaning.
But telling me right now
is not going to help me.
It's just like nagging.
Tell me when I'm near
the dry cleaner!"
So we should think about for
these nagging types of alerts,
like how can you send them so
to increase the likelihood of it
being done the most?
And the last one are what
we call fun distractions.
So this is maybe like
the only part of your day
that is kind of enjoyable.
These are fun things
you do to kill
time, like social networking,
group chats, games, and news.
And we heard people
telling us that they
check these apps so often
anyways that maybe they don't
even need a notification ever.
For example, Alexa said,
she loves this game.
"I'm so addicted.
But I hate their notifications,
like 'You have 5 more
lives!', because I
already know that.
I was going to play it anyway.
You don't need to tell me."
And this I thought
was interesting,
because if you like the game,
wouldn't you like to know?
It's a positive message, right?
You've got new lives, like maybe
someone would like to know.
But for her, she doesn't.
So maybe for some of these
types of things, maybe more
customization for each user
to decide which exactly they
want and don't want.
So this just sums up
the four quadrants
and some examples inside them.
OK.
So it's not that simple.
If only we could say, OK, for
every type of notification,
it fits exactly
there for everybody.
It's not that simple-- lots
of contextual issues here,
one of them being
the urgency scale.
SO because time is so related
to urgency, over time the way
you experience a
notification will shift.
So we came up with what we
think violation-- principles
that notifications should stick
to in order to be effective.
And when they're
violated, the notification
can move across the quadrants.
And I'll give you
some examples here.
OK.
So here are , we think,
the four principles of what
notifications should be.
The first one, I
think is most basic.
It's relevance.
Send me messages
that matter to me.
When it is not relevant, it
becomes unnecessary noise.
Denise said that she really
likes this photo apps
she just start using.
It reminds her every
day at 6:00 PM,
you didn't post a
picture of your child.
And she's like, oh, thank you.
Great.
I'll do it now.
But my mom and dad
and sister-- they
all hate it, because they're
never going to post a picture.
They just joined the
app, because they
wanted to see her pictures.
So this is just an example
of one notification--
very useful and
delightful to one user,
but very annoying and
irrelevant to the other people.
And Shelly-- she has a group
chat with five close friends.
She said they're fun, unless
you're not in it, like if she's
busy at that moment.
Then their phone just
keeps buzzing and buzzing.
And it's so annoying.
So those are just
examples of things
that were enjoyable
distractions, right,
like positive
things in your day.
But when they're
not relevant to you,
they move over into
that nagging category.
The next principle--
selectivity and differentiation.
So Noor talked about how
there's a cost of your attention
to go check a
notification, right.
It needs to be worth your
attention, so be selective.
And people said if
messages are too excessive,
I'm just going to show you out.
I'm going to shut
that source down.
If they're not
differentiated, I'll
stop noticing them over time.
For example, Angie-- she
talks about this new app
the she uses.
It "sends way too
many notifications,
like 'Breaking News-- The
president of the university is
thinking of stepping down'.
And then 'Breaking News--
He's going to step down'.
And then 'Breaking
News-- He took a step'.
She says "It's so annoying!"
And Stephen talked about a very
popular social networking app,
and how it sent him away
too many notifications.
And he deleted it.
And that's something we're
hearing more actually
across other research
that we're doing
is more people just
using the browser--
the mobile web experience--
because the app was
sending too much stuff.
We're hearing that a lot.
So those are examples again of
positive things, right-- news
that people like to read,
social networking, which is fun.
Positive things--
but because they
weren't selective or
differentiated enough
in their notifications,
it moves over
to this nagging, annoying thing
that you resent and ignore
over time.
The next one is the
principle of legitimacy.
So the importance
of the content needs
to be aligned with
the urgency signal.
When they're unimportant alerts
that are disguised as urgent,
it tricks me into
unnecessary anxiety
and I will resent that source.
And I think this is probably
the most annoying to users.
And I'll give you
some examples here.
Like Flora says,
"Sometimes I get alerts
that I don't think
need to be alerts.
Like some app reminding me
that I can buy something in it"
It's another place where
I have to eradicate
spam, which irritates me."
So sometimes-- do we all
get those notifications
where it didn't actually
benefit you in any way?
An d it all did was be
like, hey, I'm here.
Remember, I exist on your phone.
These are the ones.
They're not legitimate, and
they really get people annoyed.
We call them crying
wolf, right, because we
reserve that part
of our consciousness
for the important VIP people.
But these notifications--
they cry wolf
and they get into
your consciousness.
They stress you
out for a minute.
And you're like, oh,
I didn't even need it.
It tricked you, and it
moves over to that really
nagging category.
These are the worst offenders.
And the last principle,
action ability.
Can it be acted upon?
Tell me when I can act.
Give me options to
delay, and allow
me to find that
message again later.
And help me prioritize,
like tell me
what will happen
if I don't do it,
so I can put it on that scale of
how urgent or not urgent it is.
David said, "Sometimes I get
a notification for something
I want to do, just not
right at that moment.
And then I forget
about it later,
because I don't see it
again." and Denise-- she says,
"I hate updating my OS."
I think maybe we
feel that way too.
"So I just keep putting
it, off until one day
an app told me I can't use it
in anymore unless I update it.
Then I spent an
hour deleting things
to make more room
for the update."
It's probably happened
to some of us.
And this example is
about OS updates.
But if you think about
app updates as well,
sometimes you get
like, oh, by the way,
there's an update to the app.
And you think, OK, I don't
have to do anything about it.
You kind of leave it.
It was a nagging thing.
And then all a sudden
one day it's like, OK,
you can't use it.
And you have to drop
everything and update it.
That happened to me the
other day at the keynote.
I got a thing saying there
was activity at my front door,
because I have those cameras.
So I stressed out.
I was like, oh my
god, what's happening.
And then I opened the app.
And it's like,
there's a new version.
You have to update it.
And I couldn't get on the Wi-Fi.
And I just sit there trying
, like what's happening
at my front door.
And I couldn't update it.
[LAUGHING]
So those are
examples that things
that were nagging that you
didn't know were important yet.
But because you didn't
act on it and it
didn't make you
accountable, it moved
into eventually a
mission-critical fire
that you had to put
out in the moment.
So just to sum up the principles
that we've mentioned here,
this is what we think
notification content should
abide by.
OK.
So what does this mean
for Android and for you?
OK.
So by the end of our study,
we realized a very clearly
that the goals of developers and
users are just very different
and on kind of different planes.
Everything we've
told you so far has
been from the user's
perspective, so all this stuff
on the left side.
What users want, they just want
to stay on top of their life.
They just want to
survive, right.
Send me only what I need.
Don't interrupt me.
Don't disrupt me even more.
Give me confidence I'm going
to get those VIP notifications.
That's all they want.
But as developer, we want to
fulfill the service obligations
that we have to give.
And when there's
something new, we
want to tell people about it.
Hey, there's this new
feature or something
has changed in the service.
We believe it will
benefit their lives,
and we want to tell them, right.
And of course, we want
to promote engagement.
We spent time and money
working on these things,
and we want people to use them.
So if you look at
these two sides,
they're just very
different goals.
They're competing.
And there are different
perspectives on urgency.
So what is urgent
to the developer
may not be urgent
at all to the users.
And we acknowledge it's
challenging as developers
to know the user context.
Because everyone
is so different,
it's hard to know
what every user wants,
like what this person
wants versus another.
And so that's something that
we're working on internally,
like what kind of
data can you use,
what signals can you
get to really determine
what users want to know.
So what is Android doing?
So when in the
release, there are
some changes to notifications.
And we feel that these
will help with those people
VIP notifications, but
this is just a start.
We did this research at
the very end of last year,
but we've started to
ideate for future releases.
And our team, we're working
toward creating a long term
vision for what we believe
the notifications should do.
So what about your product?
Do you guys send notifications?
Yeah.
So for each one that
you send, we really
encourage you to think
about it this way.
What type is it?
So use that framework
that we've created.
And be honest and realistic.
Like is it a painful
Is it nagging?
Is it useful or is it not?
Like how could it
be interpreted?
And given its level
of urgency, what
is the best way to send it?
Or even better, should
you even send it?
Is it offering any benefit?
Or is it merely just,
hey, look at our app,
like we still exist.
And again, be honest
and realistic.
And how can the notification
enhance the user experience
of the service?
This might be the most
challenging to do.
There are some really
good notifications
were it actually enhances
the whole service
and your experience of it.
What can you do to respect
your users' attention
and help them complete
tasks that they care about?
We're all in this together
in this game, right.
Like if some apps are sending
too many notifications, abusing
people's attention, it affects
how users think of other apps.
And it affects their decision.
The next time
there's an app, they
may not want to try it at all.
We heard people say, I don't
even want to download the app.
I'm just going to go
to the mobile website.
Or they may download an app
and just block notifications
from the start.
Right.
What we do affects other
experiences as well.
So today, we told you
about real people's lives.
We told you about the
attachment and the addiction
to phones because
of notifications.
We told you about
all the distractions
that people are managing, as
they're just trying to survive
and get through their day.
We need to spread the word and
start a movement for everyone
to realize how disruptive
our notifications can be,
and what we can
do to change this.
We feel that we have
the responsibility
to respect all of
our users' attention.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]